kelly clarkson filed for divorce from
her husband brandon blackstock back in
june 2020. and now a source tells et she
is ready to put her marriage behind her
but she's not happy she has to pay 150
000 per month in spousal support you
know it's just divorce is a really
thing
last week et learned that the 39 year
old singer's prenuptial agreement has
been validated by the judge in her
divorce case the prenup segregates all
assets and income derived during her
marriage to the 44 year old talent
manager and gives her possession of the
montana ranch where he is currently
living it's also where their family
quarantined together in 2020. now a
source tells et quote kelly is ready to
put her marriage behind her and move on
from her ex brandon kelly is extremely
happy her prenup was held up and she
gets what she worked so hard for last
month a judge ruled that kelly will pay
her ex 150 000 per month in spousal
support as well as 45
601 dollars per month in child support
and pay 1.25 million towards brandon's
attorney fees and costs for their
ongoing divorce now e.t source says
quote she's not happy to be paying 150
000 to brandon in spousal support but is
hoping once the divorce is finalized
that amount will be lowered kelly filed
for divorce in june 2020 after nearly
seven years of marriage they share two
children together seven-year-old river
rose and five-year-old remington
alexander and in november 2020 she won
primary custody of the kids but et
source adds that kelly is still thankful
for her relationship with brandon adding
quote she learned a lot about herself
and had two perfect kids kelly is
looking forward to moving on and
successfully co-parenting with brandon
and we might just get some good music
out of the whole thing et spoke to kelly
in february and she said she's written
60 songs during her divorce process i
have this record
that
we're working on that
is
is really great and it's very honest um
it's just there's just like a lot of
there's a lot of questions that i just
have to answer before releasing it for
myself whatever
happens though it is such a gift like i
don't know how anybody i'll just be real
with you goes through
grief like divorce any kind of grief any
kind of loss without having an outlet
like it has i have written like 60 songs
like
it's like an insane amount of getting it
out
um you know and i think that that's a
blessing in itself anytime you go
through some lives like it's a such an
awesome thing to have that as an outlet
regardless if people hear it or not
not everybody has that